are you ready for the rematch we're just
four days away from the nation's first
presidential primary in New Hampshire
but it looks like the general election
is already getting started both Joe
Biden and Donald Trump are ramping up
the trash talk my predecessors like to
say America is a failing
nation in my face bless me Father for
his sin I mean come
on a failing nation and by the way did
you hear he wants to see the stock
market crash you know why he doesn't
want to be the next Herbert Hoover as I
told him he's already Hoover he can't
put two sentences together he can't find
the stairs off a stage which there are a
lot of them up there believe me they're
all over the place he can't find his way
off a stage when he makes a very short
speech and it has to be short because it
can't be long Trump isn't the only one
taking shots at Biden listen to what
Andrew Yang had to say about President
Biden while endorsing Democratic
presidential Challenger and Congressman
Dean
Phillips a lot of Americans have made up
their minds about this President and
this economy and telling them that it's
better is not a working
strategy the second thing is that the
president is 81 years
old it's going to be tough to reinvent
Grandpa he's not going to become a new
candidate that Grandpa has got to sting
because it's true Joe Biden acts like a
grandpa all the time the big guy was
just drinking a triple thi milkshake and
searching for a congresswoman who wasn't
even in the
room I got call home black and white no
iceam chocolate Shir
Tri I also want to mention Congress
Deborah Ross where's
Deborah she I just had my picture taken
with her oh she couldn't be be here
actually that's not true I got it mixed
up St and while Joe looks weak Trump
looks stronger than ever Senator Tim
Scott will be endorsing Trump later
tonight at a rally in Concord New
Hampshire and Scott just dropped this
tease oh man I'm so excited for the
announcement tonight just tune in pay
attention listen closely and let's talk
about four more
years okay Martha I'll start with you so
Joe Biden is criticizing Donald Trump
for saying that we are a failed nation
when the truth is the economy is in the
tank inflation's out of control we've
got immigration not just overrunning
cities towns and Villages but
bankrupting hospitals and crime is out
of control without any solution in sight
you know I think back to president
Trump's inaugural address when he talked
about the things that were really
hurting in the country and he used the
word Carnage at points and I think then
people understood that the country was
headed in a direction that was that was
scary that was Troublesome so then we
had four years then we had to deal with
covid right and it and it appears that
the current president is not ingesting
the feeling of the country so yes I
think if you ask a lot of people and I
think it's evident in many of the polls
that people are very concerned that the
country is failing that the country is
falling behind that our great cities are
not what they once were that we are
worried about the fact that our children
aren't educated you can graduate from
high school in this country barely able
to read so he is he he fails often to
meet the moment of where people are in
the country and I think if he could
speak to people in a way that reached
them and had that kind of you know Bill
Clinton I I feel your pain people
believed him when he said that that he
understood what was going on around
their dinner table and it there's a
disconnect and I think that you sense it
all the time that's why he's at
33% % that is an abysmal approval number
now what happens in a head-to-head Trump
Biden I think is anybody's guess that
that's it that's an interesting matchup
once again um we see what the swing
state PS look like they look good for
Trump right now but I think you got to
wonder if there's going to be a third
party who kind of throws a wrench into
some of the balance here on these
numbers and we'll see what happens yeah
all right peers I mean Trump says that
Joe Biden can't put two sentences
together that he doesn't know which way
to walk off stage what is what do people
uh in Europe think Donald of Joe Biden
and the fact that you know he's got
these issues well look I know I'm I'm in
the official liberal chair tonight but
i' I've got
nothing let's be clear um I think
Democrats are sleepwalking into a
ludicra situation they all know I mean
two-thirds of Democrats think he's too
old two-thirds of his own party think
he's too old to run again but he's
insisting on doing it obviously nobody
wants to give up the most powerful
office in the world I get that but but
Joe Biden to me is a dead man walking
and if the Democrats don't wake up fast
to the reality of their candidate the
incumbent barely alive president against
a resurgent Donald Trump who has just
had the biggest win at the Iowa caucus
in Republican history and who by the way
in 2016 when he became president didn't
even win in Iowa if that doesn't ring
massive alarm Bells then I don't know
what does and of course the dynamic is
so different the 2020 because when Joe
Biden ran against Trump then it was off
the back of a ruinous pandemic which had
ruined all of Trump's calculations and
would have been incredibly difficult for
anybody actually to win at the end of
incredibly difficult and Biden ran as
the anti-trump candidate well he can't
do that again now he he has to run on
his own record and as Martha said 33% is
it I mean this I don't think any
incumbent president in history has won
with that approval rate at the stage
right so to me the Democrats have to
wake up will they will they get a new
candidate in maybe it's too late they've
done it twice before where they've had
incumbent Democrat Presidents since
World War II who have stepped aside I
think they should do that otherwise I've
got to say and I I did not think I'd be
saying this a year ago I really didn't I
thought Trump was done and then when you
think 91 criminal charges he has to be
done but it's bit like with King Kong on
top of the buildings here the more they
plunged into his back the more powerful
he got and I look at Trump now I've
known him a long time and my God that
guy's got resilience and he has got
a a gate to his a wind behind his gate
which says to me he thinks he's going to
win and I think honestly I suspect we'll
be here in November and if Joe Biden's
up against him Trump wins you know Tyrus
Biden if Biden thinks that Trump is the
next Herbert Hoover I mean he doesn't he
doesn't understand numbers because his
numbers on the economy are 30% where
Trump's was always 50 or over you know I
would have loved to someone follow up
because there's no follow-up questions
anymore uh how so how is he Herbert
Hoover yeah and he would be like I don't
want to talk about vacuums right now he
has absolutely no clue what's going on
but here's the here's right now take the
polls out of it America is we are looked
at we're we're a cowardice Nation right
now we don't respect women we had mour
women in the in the Senate talking about
their children our representative didn't
even show up they were attacked and that
was the status quo there's no reason to
give up power because he's not in power
Andrew who I respect he's not you can't
reinvent Grandpa because he's not
Grandpa he doesn't even claim his own
grandchildren there is no reason for
because progress Democrats aren't
running the these are not Democrats I I
can I have no problem loing losing an
election to a everything might not go my
way but the they're
Democrats this is socialism and
progressivism using an elderly man who
can't remember what day of the week it
is as their puppet that's why he only
has two s he can't put two sentences
together he puts three or four together
that's the problem he's just a puppet
and there is no way in blue hell that
they're going to give that up because
they are getting stuff that even 50
years that he's been in in government
he's never been this far M but he has no
clue what's going on so there's no and
they're not going to run against Trump
there will be no debates because he's
not going to debate with a Criminal I've
said it over and over again they're
going to use all the stuff they set up
to not debate him they're going to run
on what they think is going to get him
to the finish line but the problem is
the American people do not like being
known as cowards even with what's going
on in the Middle East if if england
didn't do something then we did it but
when we're left to do something we don't
do it we blow up empty buildings and
that's the problem so in the economy it
doesn't matter Americans don't feel good
about this country right now period all
right Charlie Martha brought up the
issue of uh no labels and the
possibility of a third- Party candidate
uh how how do you think that that's
going to happen uh I think that probably
uh we'll see something like that happen
whether it's them or some other Third
Party candidate what's kind of
interesting about it is if you do see
that what is the third party candidate
going to do they're going to try to run
on in entirely Trump's agenda because
that's a winning agenda and if you take
the personalities out of it Donald Trump
wins this election by you know with 60
70% of the vote everybody agrees with
Donald Trump on all the issues some
unsolicited advice for uh Joe Biden
don't get into a trash talking contest
with Donald Trump nobody uh fares well
in those things with Donald Trump
especially not you uh Joe Biden it's not
going to end well and when when Joe
Biden talks about how Trump is trashing
the country and says we're off failed
nation and what no he's not that's like
the ver the political version of a human
shield where you say he's attacking
American PE no he's not he's saying
you're a failure and you know what you
are a failure and when he talks about
the economy and how Trump wants the
economy to fail no he's predicting that
the economy is in shambles as you point
out Martha and and uh and and they're
completely disconnected from that and
you know you can look at the stock
market and say okay the stock market is
is you know setting new records
but and That's a classic mistake the
politicians fail politicians politicians
who go on to lose always make they think
oh well the the stock market's doing
great yeah it's not doing great if you
can't afford groceries and people are
complaining about it and it's all can be
tied directly directly to your policies
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else